Dear Fellow Scholars - this is Two Minute
Papers with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér,
It is time for some minds to be blown - we
are going to talk about a philosophy paper.
Before we start, a quick definition - an ancestor
simulation is a hypothetical computer simulation
that is detailed enough that the entities
living within are conscious. Imagine a computer
game that you play that doesn't contain mere
digital characters, but fully conscious beings
with feelings, aspirations and memories.
There are many interesting debates among philosophers
on crazy elusive topics, like "prove to me
that I'm not in a dream", or "I'm not just
a brain in a bottle somewhere that is being
fed sensory inputs." Well, good luck.
In his paper, Nick Bostrom, philosopher offers
us a refreshing take on this topic, and argues
that at least one of the three propositions
is true:
- almost all advanced civilizations go extinct
before achieving technological maturity,
- there is a strong convergence among technologically
mature civilizations in that none of them
are interested in creating ancestor simulations.
and here's the bomb
- we are living in a simulation
At least one of these propositions is true,
so if you say no to the first two, then the
third is automatically true. You cannot categorically
reject all three of these because if two are
false, the third follows. Also, the theory
doesn't tell which of the three is true.
Let's talk briefly about the first one. The
argument is not that [we go] extinct before
being technologically advanced enough to create
such simulations. It means that all civilizations
do. This is a very sad case, and even though
there is research on the fact that war is
receding there's a clear trend that
we have less warfare than we've had hundreds of years ago. (I've linked a video on this here from Kurzgesagt) It is still possible that humanity
eradicates itself before before reaching technological
maturity. We have an even more powerful argument
that maybe all civilizations do. Such a crazy
proposition.
Second point. All technologically mature civilizations
categorically reject ancestor simulations.
Maybe they have laws against is because it's
too cruel and unethical to play with sentient
beings. But the fact that there is not [one
person] in any civilization in any age who
creates such a simulation. Not one criminal
mastermind, anywhere, ever. This also sounds
pretty crazy.
And if none of these are true, then there
is at least one civilization that can run
a stupendously large number of ancestor simulations.
The future nerd guy just goes home, grabs
a beer, starts his computer in the basement
and fires up not a simple computer game, but
a complete universe. If so, then there are
many more simulated universes than real ones,
and then with a really large probability,
we're one of the simulated ones. Richard Dawkins
says that if this is the case, we have a really
disciplined nerd guy, because the laws of
physics are not changing at a whim, we have
no experience of everyone suddenly being able
to fly.
And, as the closing words of the paper states
with graceful eloquence:
In the dark forest of our current ignorance,
it seems sensible to apportion one’s credence
roughly evenly between (1), (2), and (3).
Please note that this discussion is a slightly
simplified version of the manuscript, so it's
definitely worth reading the paper, if you're
interested, give it a a go. As always, I've
put a link in the description box.
There is no conclusion here, no one really
knows what the answer is, this is open to
debate, and this is what makes it super interesting.
And my personal opinions, conclusion. It's
just an opinion, it may not be true, it may
not make sense, and may not even matter. Just
my opinion. I'd go with the second. The reason
for that is that we already have artificial
neural networks that outperform humans on
some tasks. They are still not general enough,
which means that they are good at doing something,
like the deep blue is great at chess, but
it's not really useful for anything else.
However, the algorithms are getting more and
more general, and the number of neurons that
are being simulated on a graphical card in
your computer are doubling every few years.
They will soon be able to simulate so many
more connections than we have, and I feel
that creating an artificial superintelligent
being should be possible in the future, that
is so potent that it makes universe simulation
pale in comparison. What such a thing could
be capable of, it's already getting too long,
I just can't help myself. You know what? Let's
discuss it in a future Two Minute Papers episode.
I'd love to hear what you Fellow Scholars
think about these things. If you feel like
it, leave your thoughts in the comments section
below.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!